moi c'est mes enfants voient ça à la
télé je casse la télé en fait
inacceptable de mettre déjà l'enfant
s'il perd déjà tellement de construction
déjà tellement compliqué sans parler de
l'adolescence qui s'ensuit et en plus on
vous met dans la tête que vous n'êtes
pas dans le bon sexe
c'est la laisser là on sait très bien ce
qu'il ya derrière est en train de dire
quoi derrière moi derrière mais si
grande qu'on l'a connue
mais c'est une propagande de 2 voilà
deux de certains lobbys qui veulent
mettre dans la tête des enfants qui se
sont peut-être trompés c'est une
propagande aussi pour mettre en avant
les droits d'une minorité et ce à la
rigueur c'est une autre question mais
pourquoi les enfants vous attendent et
pourtant elle a eu son mal-être toute sa
vie mais j'apprécie ce volet qui se
suicide après avoir transitionner
faudrait peut-être qu'on en parle aussi
de cela doit être une instabilité aussi
il ya peut-être aller énormément non
mais j'ai ces gens qui se suicident
parce qu'ils ont transitionner c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont transitionner ils se
suicident parce qu'à tellement de haine
de
l'association ya bien des domaines en ag
lundi section au royaume uni ou ensuite
qui font demi tour justement parce
qu'ils étaient dans un livre de
propagande attention je suis de
propagande devant justement vous êtes
enfin trop de faire trop sonné les
enfants qui se poseraient des questions
il se rend compte de l'impact jouera
tous dans mitto d'arrêter les gens qui
conditionne 100 % des gens qui
transition c'est justement par rapport à
la haine de la société la haine de la
société parce que les gens ne voient pas
ce genre de film
mais
je suppose que tu es tu penses que tf1
n'aurait jamais dû diffuser ce film
retrace
alors je vous dis c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle le téléfilm n'a pas marché du
mois de mai va pas se mentir la logique
non c'est vrai mais c'est bien s'est mis
d'accord il en vient en fait et je sais
pas pourquoi mais c'est vrai que ça peut
ça peut poser des questions parce que
c'est comme ça c'est mais non non non
non c'est magnifique on allait chez
restée non les grosses productions je
vous dis la vérité ça fait deux ans que
c'est dans les tiroirs moi je vous dis
la vérité j'aurai et j'aurais aimé que
ça fasse 6,7 millions hier oui j'étais
assez déçu lé score et même tout le
monde était déçu parce que c'était une
très grosse production pour tf1 ça fait
deux ans que c'est dans les tiroirs un
tf1 hésité à le à le diffuser et
finalement ils ont diffusé hier soir un
jour férié je pense franchement et moi
c'est mon coup de gueule quelle erreur
de diffuser ça
erreur de programmation telle erreur en
amont table celui qui a programmé ça un
jour un jour férié comme ça c'est sait
et c'est pas la bonne programmation
puisque je vous dis c'est vrai qu'un
autre chose aurait fait beaucoup plus on
aurait aimé que ce téléfilm passe à 5 6
millions et ils l'ont été il a été
pénalisé je vous dis par la
programmation en jour ce dernier hier
c'était comme un dimanche soir un là on
est unanime et serré que c'était comme
un dimanche soir c'était un jour férié
et c'est vrai que c'est plutôt les
grosses productions voilà la très
familial qui marche et c'est vrai que là
voilà on aurait mis un jeudi soir ou un
autre soit un autre lundi soir serait
beaucoup mieux marché là je trouve
qu'ils ont un petit peu jeté voilà le
maître lundi soir comme ça un 1er
novembre si c'était une connerie moi oui
s'il lui moi luis mercé moi je dis bravo
tf1 d'avoir fait ça tente de faire
évoluer un peu les mentalités il faut
savoir qu'il ya quand même à peu près
quinze mille n'y a pas d'étude très
sérieuse là dessus mais une estimation
de 15000 transgenres en france et cela
dit comme vous l'avez dit madame se doit
les aider un peu et je dis bravo qu'ils
le fassent on va voir infractions les
enfants mais
qu'avaient ya pas d tout paraît toujours
fort vous savez moi je veux dire à des
impacts et ça va être très
chaud c'est ce que c'est la connaissance
n'y avait pas non plus
6 existait pas j'ai dit que je vois bien
le métro reporter
je vous parlais pas des jeux et
structures de lille
alors il ya une autre scène rien je suis
sûr que
s'il vous plaît